my name is Jill Berkman and I live in
Louisville Kentucky
I took the Foundation's class for Dave
Ramsey when I was a senior in high
school and looking at colleges and
trying to figure out what I wanted to
major anymore learned to go and it
really helped encourage me and really
help teach me about really what debt is
and why I don't want to tack that onto
myself in the long run I've been taking
the class I didn't just sit there and
fill in the blanks and watch the videos
and then go on and forget everything
that I had learned but I actually had to
implement it so I was able to work at a
preschool and nanny and babysit my way
through college and I made some
sacrifices of you know some nights a
week I was able to stay out really late
and hang out and some nights I had to go
to bed early so I could get up and go to
work in the morning rather than go to
the really expensive private schools I
ended up living at home and going to the
local community college instead which
was not what I wanted to do at all and
it ended up working out very very nicely
and just being the perfect place for me
to be and during that time at the
community college I ended up earning two
associate's degrees I transferred to the
University of Louisville which is the
local university and just absolutely
loved my time here I ended up working as
a student missionary through the North
American Mission Board to the University
of Louisville and it was just great
being able to work and do school and
just live life I was able to have a
great relationship with my parents and
maintain that partially just because we
don't have that burden or that extra
burden of debt and loans at the end of
it I was nominated by my professors as
one of four outstanding undergraduate
students in my major and graduated on
time with honors so I'm able to wait
patiently and just keep working how I
have been
while waiting for the right job to come
along because I don't have that threat
or the hanging cloud of student loans
hanging over my head